let's bring in ups healthcare president
wes wheeler
he's been working closely with operation
warp speed and pfizer and he joins us
now from the ups command center in
louisville
good morning to you mr wheeler i just
want to paint a picture
for viewers right now in a typical
december ups
is very busy in this december with the
pandemic shipping
you're extra busy and now you layer on
top of all of that the fact you're
shipping vaccines
something that's literally life or death
just if you could take us
inside that command center how are
things feeling at the moment
we're very excited here of course uh we
we had the first shipment of vaccines
come in here last night
uh yesterday afternoon actually uh
captain houston mills flew the first
plane in we unloaded the plane
we distributed through our short
facility here and then we
put all the vaccines out to the rest of
the country outbound on flights last
night
and all of those vaccines now are
sitting at the market at the destination
ready to be offloaded
i do want to pause and just sit for a
moment at what this this moment in our
history means it was back in february
when we first started hearing
that this was going to be bad the
pandemic had no vaccine
no treatments now we have that vaccine
what was it like for you
40 years in this industry to see that
plane land in louisville and to know
that the process
had begun the beginning of the end i
think the beginning of the end is the
way to describe it i mean the way we
felt of course we're elated we've been
working on this with warp speed for four
or five months now
and all the lanes that we've designed
all these all these weeks and months
with them
designing the right capacity to make
sure we could do this during our
peak season was uh was an amazing moment
for all of us it really
brought chills for me i bet and
at the holidays on top of it all what
should people
expect as you embark on this very
complicated process
uh you know in a normal scenario it
would be reasonable to expect that not
every shipment would be successful
as the days and the hours stretch before
us should we anticipate and do you
anticipate hearing that
some things have gone wrong
no not at all i mean i think we've
described a couple of times we have a
special
label this has a bluetooth enabled radio
inside
uh every shipment of every vaccine that
came from pfizer
will have one of these labels on that
box that gives us visibility inside of
all of our facilities
in the country on top of that we're
we're monitoring gps location
so we have a lot of redundancy in how we
can see these vaccines
so imagine that during the christmas
season we have a lot of packages
25 million per day on average of course
the vaccines are flowing through the
same network
but we're giving them priority so as
they come in everybody knows their first
priority in our system
our pilots know that they're flying them
our drivers know that
they're driving them and so we can make
sure that even though the christmas
packages are running
that the vaccines will be running in a
priority manner and how long are you
anticipating uh
doing this how long have you prepared
for uh the biden administration has said
100 million
shots in 100 days today is day one
but this stretch is indefinitely for you
at ups
we're prepared to do this for whatever
it takes i think we'll be doing this for
perhaps years and you know that we
remove
flu vaccines every year 60 million
vaccines per year this is not new to us
but the fact that this is minus 100
degrees fahrenheit more or less
makes it a little bit more challenging
but we're prepared to do this all the
way through the season whatever it takes
yeah people may not realize the order's
coming in
every day you ship the flu vaccines you
also ship organs uh you know the
healthcare
shipping division is significant there
which you had
i know the fact that this is happening
in december uh
is inconvenient probably logistically
you've got so much else going on
but is it also significant to you that
this would happen
during the holiday season
of course i mean you could also imagine
that uh we're delivering
our own christmas present to the
american people into the world i mean
the vaccine is the beginning of the end
of this pandemic we're very excited to
do that
uh and the fact that it's at christmas
time it wasn't planned that way but here
it is and
we're very happy to deliver for
everybody it is a gift to the american
people uh mr west wheeler thank you very
much
thank you very much thanks for having me